[Musik]
[Applaus]
mir wäre zum kleinen der medien
dargestellt als umweltzerstörer als
birne oder
[Musik]
wenn die pflanzenschutzmittel ausbringen
statisch eigentlich nun oder der bühne
habe ich bin in lima und ich glaube die
meisten sind in kiel immer du hier sind
gemacht worden dass buchbar teilt man
als inside fiel schlecht probleme möchte
zieht spielt
erzählt sie trotzdem fährt ski
pflanzenschutzmittel durchhängt und ich
alles alles okay also zu früh angefangen
definitiv
kein
top drauf da weiß ich noch als pure
heimreisen immer das eigentlich
zugelassen hätten ja ich war
[Musik]
ich glaube die massenproduktion von
lebensmitteln hat mich krank gemacht die
agrochemie ist eine davon
[Musik]
ich träume von einer welt in der man
essen kann ohne sich zu vergiften
[Musik]
max kaminski
lebensinhalt schock sündigen sport aber
nicht wir hätten eigentlich schon
früheren romanen zeigen dass der stoff
nicht unproblematisch ist
ich meinte der 80er jahre hit man das
eigentlich schon müssen realisieren dass
für den chemiker ist es eigentlich klar
aber primär ist das natürliche aufgabe
zu er stellt aber dann hat jetzt zur
urlaubszeit der klasse sein
[Musik]
sind sicher fehler passiert
ich mache mir diesen film zu
perspektiven und auch gedacht die stadt
gekommen waren hier selbst wenn sie sind
psychologie macht es sinn wenn ich da
meinen auszutesten also ganz gestimmt
weil wir wissen ja dass pestizide
weiters gebe nämlich vorhanden sind und
kann das auch eine gefahr sein wenn sie
sagen lässt die zieht es in die bahn das
kann durchaus sein dass man durchaus
auch mit relativ geringen belastungen
wenn man sie hat über einen langen
zeitraum immer wieder art durchaus
probleme bekommen kann
der konsument muss ich natürlich schwer
bewusst sie es ist keine heilige
landwirtschaft sowie es zum teil mit der
werbiger dargestellt wird von der
grossverteiler wie stets in der realität
auch im biologischen bauwerber
pflanzenschutzmittel gesetzt natürlich
viel weniger und es sind biologische
mittel wir sind auf einem rapsfeld hier
werden pestizide eingesetzt die sehr
schädlich für die umwelt sind
was ist der schlüssel
der letzte
buch zurück flogen
und leite eigentlich in steigender linie
weitere dreier und das hat zur folge
dass nachher der stadt platzt und dann
redet man von matrox verlust von 20 30
bis 40 40 prozent erst wenn viele
schädlinge auftreten darf anbauer
pestizid spritzen
schön
historischer tropfen
wäre er biobauer könnte mich heute
frauenfelder den stangen rösler nicht
bekämpfen seien ertrag würde schwanken
und damit auch sein lohn viel einfacher
geht es mit synthetischen pestiziden
es ist für uns versichert dass wir einen
ertrag hängt ein sicherer ertrag zu
einem hohen preis
[Musik]
mit spritzen holster das ist
spiritualität stange rösler das ist
vermutlich krebs schädigend und das ist
sehr giftig für wasserlebewesen mit lang
anhaltende wirkung
genau also ist natürlich nicht einfach
um bedenkenlos zum setzte es gar nicht
nur und wasser die aber es gab auch
andere insekten auf dem feld ziehen dass
ich mir dann ja mal primär steinhäusler
bekämpfen
es wird aber wahrscheinlich auch noch
andere insekten
treffen ob der mittel das ist ganz klar
mit einer schlacht wisse jetzt wenn man
das sie setzt ja
jetzt nicht dass ich da
in einer selbstfindungsphase
schweizergarde ja mein gott darf
coesfeld und der hand aus und wenn es
ein spritzer den haben ja personen
ertragsverlust dass die kultur genauso
gut könne machen oder
[Musik]
rund 60 km entfernt ein bauch
stellvertretend für viele inmitten
intensiver landwirtschaft
der sls bach ist noch ziemlich pestizid
belastet also ich glaube man hat fast 90
verschiedene pestizide gefunden werte
sind ja schon teilweise ziemlich
überschritten ja was hätten weiter
festgestellt
2014 der schock massenhaft tote
bachflohkrebse und köcherfliegenlarven
wegen pestiziden ein teil des bauchs tot
im letzten jahrzehnt ist die fangquote
von bachforellen schweizweit um 40
prozent geschrumpft
durch den klimawandel steigen die
wassertemperaturen
und die wärme der bach desto stärker
werden fische durch pestizide geschädigt
sagt biologin inge wärmer die fische die
bei 15 grad die pestizide abbekommen
haben haben also wesentlich stärker
negativ reagiert als die fische bei
zwölf grad zb den pestiziden ausgesetzt
waren in dem sie um zum schwimmen mehr
energie gebraucht haben das sind effekte
die sich langfristig dann doch auswirken
auf den fisch das schlechtere
überlebenschancen hat für kleintiere im
bauch sind die pestizide die auch im
raps gespritzt werden am gefährlichsten
es sind für ihre truiden
nervengifte das können sich viele gar
nicht vorstellen wie wenig es braucht ja
um so ein tierchen zu schädigen wir sind
in gramm pro liter bereich und wenn sie
da an die neunte stelle hinterm komma
gehen dann sind sie in dem nanogramm
bereich nanogramm pro liter und es
reicht schon um schädigungen zu
verursachen
und deshalb muss wirklich sagen jeder
tropfen zählt
doch noch mehr jobs mehr ich hart trifft
ukraine reinigung ruf ich das nicht bin
dass ich eigentlich muss meiner sicht
alles richtig machen
die auflagen sind streng aber eine
untersuchung des wwf vor vier jahren im
st galler rheintal zeigte 20 prozent der
bauern hielten den abstand zu gewässern
nicht ein
der bund hat ein bienengift verboten es
lag direkt auf den rapssamen musste also
nicht gespritzt werden
ersetzt wurde das bienengift
durchführe druide jetzt bin ich so
breitflächig spectrobes entflogen
spritze dann vermutlich abitur ob sind
nützling sowie schädling
viel wusste ich kann mir auch nicht aber
deine natürlich so auf den deckel
also hat mir der teufel mit dem
beelzebub austreiben
haben wir ziemlich genau was sie
eigentlich beschrieben und ja sie
schaffe außerdem sind keine lösung wenn
man dauernd das ist definitiv so
[Musik]
die forscherinnen untersuchen leber und
hirne der bachforellen auch auf
pyrethroide wenn ihre nerven nicht nicht
die die die impulse richtig weiter
leuten dann passiert es orientierung die
organismen können sich nicht mehr
richtig bewegen sie sind unkoordiniert
und irgendwann sterben ca
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht dass die hintergründe
sind warum wir so viel raps anbauen
müssen in der schweiz ist einfach wer
dass man die umwelt so belastet um
diesen ort zu geben
schweizer rapsöl wird speziell beworben
im gegensatz zu sonnenblumenöl dabei
können sonnenblumen praktisch ohne
pestizide angebaut werden
rund um den mit pestizid belasteten
angeles bach stehen auch viele
obstkulturen
[Musik]
bedroht durch zehn verschiedene
schädlinge dazu pilze und bakterien
krankheiten
roland kreis arbeitet für den größten
thurgauer produzenten
[Musik]
was für pestizid bruch wer beruflich
kontakt fungizid kaptan
verschiedene nicht so denn das sind
2 467 verschiedene
mittelamerika blatt jüngere zur mit bio
bio aktivator dazu und sind die cds
sind vier pestizide drei davon schützen
die apfelbäume vor den pilzkrankheiten
shorts und mild haben
wie viel spritziger braucht ein bisschen
rief ich verdammt das sind ungefähr 18
bis 20 spritzige
weniger mit weniger der
sache wenn wir schon verkaufen oder mehl
darin kaufen und da bin ich doch also
mails gilt vor allem für bilder und auch
lara gang menü hübsche jemand zum teil
york über touren da heißt die man eben
am lager haben welche qualität
sicher dass auch wäre er biobauer wird
die roland kreis die äpfel rund doppelt
so oft spritzen weil die mittel weniger
regenfest sind zwar sind sie weniger
schädlich aber er müsste mehr traktor
fahren und würde mehr diesel verbrauchen
ich darf nicht schranken giftschlamms
richtig dass aus sicherheitsgründen
sind richtig zieht
human noch mehr auszahlen
das macht das gift
warum sprühte mir auch los muss ab jetzt
nicht mehr spritzen dann nötig wenn
bienen
aber damit jetzt
beginnen das danke dass das sehr giftig
ist für wasserorganismen und sogar in
die multi bestätige ich dass
das muss natürlich sicherheitshalber
macht also ich wäre
man beachte und mehr tönte als opfer
sehen wir die letzten momente die
irgendwo
welt setzen
der zugführer hannover druckspuren und
die mieter kann man bloß er gewiss nie
normal
auf die spülmittel vom 5 von der
hausfrau
täglichen mittel die griechen drauf sehr
giftig für wasserlebewesen und
ja also ich wäre da vorsichtig mit wenn
sie zur sache und stehen auf höhere
semester
mit trinken
das bienengift ist unterdessen verboten
pro landkreis hat vor 45 jahren als
obstbauer begonnen
[Musik]
der anspruch an
ich kann ihn mir
auf und
unternehmen über 20 jahre ja es gibt
eine studie aus meinem buch egal wenn es
besteht über längere zeit gesetzt dann
hat er uns 50 prozent höheres pfadfinder
und risiken
und jetzt mitte kann es wird somit
also wenn einem in einem verdacht die
ständer denn wenn ihrer leute manchmal
stockt
[Musik]
dieser cocktail wird auf die apfelbäume
gespritzt
[Musik]
der handel bewegt und wir als
konsumentinnen und konsumenten ist ein
apfel nicht perfekt verliert der bauer
zwei drittel der einnahmen
2 class er spaß der ist voll
ausbildet hat der schöne tv und daheim
ein testspiel unter rühren
durchsucht waren wenig wenn ich also zu
fuß unterwegs ist braucht sehr wenigen
als ist der handel nicht standsicher
strengen also ist strenger mann
überführen und als ganzes
[Musik]
und wie viele pestizidrückstände sind im
geernteten opfer
der liga oder die stammten regel nachdem
er damit am schluss mit der
rückstand nun
also derzeit nur noch vier prozent
einbruch mit minus 4 sie das könnte auch
das eine oder zwei richtige medizin also
das heißt dass sie ganz genau was
bestritt richtig der mittel wird die
grünliche sie sind absolut unbedenklich
bis pink
und rot sind da man bereits
bitte bitte bloß nach der blüte
opel-spitze verwenden kommt aus dass
hunt
flanz berater die kombination mit der
lagerhaltung tobi ich stand rat sehr
wichtig jetzt
[Musik]
sicher
weil aufgeben wir mehr über abstützen
die behörden bestimmen wie viel gift in
einem apfel sein darf dass wir nicht
geschädigt werden der apfel ist aber nur
ein kleiner teil unserer nahrung was
heißt das für unsere gesundheit
seit dieser recherche habe ich
mehrheitlich auf bio umgestellt
ja wir haben von ihm jahre urinprobe
erhalten von diesen acht parameter nicht
aber ihn untersucht haben
tatsächlich hat auch vier von diesen
parametern positiv nachweisen können man
kann sagen und durchaus den faktor 10
geringer als das was den oberen bereich
der allgemeinbevölkerung außen also
durchaus wirklich eine sehr moderate
belastung und heißt das jetzt dass das
nicht schädlich ist was er sagt mein
wert über die schädigung hat das
vergleichen halt mit der allgemeinen
bevölkerung gibt halt nur wieder halt wo
sie statistisch gegen es ist kein keine
keine größenordnung die man verwenden
kann um kosmologische beurteilt sie dies
weil es noch zu wenig daten gibt wie
sich pestizide im menschen verhalten und
bei der zulassung untersuchen die
behörden nur ein einzelnes pestizid
statt des cocktails den wir zu uns
nehmen
gerade diese mischung leistung ist
durchaus ein thema und da wissen wir
auch noch ganz am anfang wie jetzt das
ende jetzt für die verschiedenen stoffe
grenzwerte haben bisher noch in vielen
fällen noch gar nicht wie sie dann
miteinander wirken also ob sie sich
potenzieren oder ob sich addieren all
diese aspekte sind oftmals gar nicht so
gut untersucht also ist das ganze ein
bisschen eine blackbox diese pestizid zu
lassen das gilt durchaus
blackbox pestizid zulassung im keller
des bundesamts für landwirtschaft lagern
über 1000 ordner
es sind sicherheitsstudien finanziert
und in auftrag gegeben von pestizid
herstellern rund 175 gesuche werden
jährlich eingereicht am aufwändigsten
sind gesuche für neue wirkstoffe bis zu
80 bundesordner mit rund 70.000 seiten
an daten pro gesuch wie einer der
hersteller sagt
gerade mal 5,2 vollzeitstellen prüfen
die studien auf risiken für die menschen
das vergleichbare österreich beschäftigt
doppelt so viele toxikologen man sei
überfordert sagte mir eine quelle aus
dem inneren des bundesamts
die gift studien sind vertraulich
geschäftsgeheimnis der pestizid
hersteller nur die behörden haben den
vollen einblick und auch ihre berichte
sind geheim
[Musik]
das bundesamt für landwirtschaft seit
anfang jahr nicht mehr zuständig für die
zulassung von pestiziden zu große nähe
zu den interessen der bauern befand der
bundesrat
er transferierte die verantwortung zum
bundesamt für lebensmittelsicherheit und
veterinärwesen
und hier will niemand ein interview vor
der kamera geben trotz mehrmaliger
nachfrage und trotz des verweises auf
das große öffentliche interesse
dabei wurde den behörden in einem
bericht der kpmg 2009/10 mangelnde
transparenz vorgeworfen
deutschland und frankreich
veröffentlichen ihre berichte zu
pestiziden seit jahren warum tut dass
die schweiz nicht
per mail schreibt das bundesamt es gebe
keine rechtliche grundlage
die dafür benötigten ressourcen sind
daher nicht vorhanden
dabei könnte die behörde selbst
änderungen anregen interne protokolle
zeigen nämlich schon 2017 wollten einige
beamte pestizid berichtet der
bevölkerung zugänglich machen
ein wichtiger punkt gemäss ist das
fehlende vertrauen in die behörden
jemand anders aber meinte dass das zu
diskussionen mit der industrie führen
würde
[Musik]
diese dokumente habe ich dank dem
öffentlichkeitsgesetz heraus verlangen
können
und was auf die zulassungsstelle zum
risiko von pestizid cocktails in der
mail schreibt sie gemäss den verfügbaren
wissenschaftlichen daten gibt es
momentan keine hinweise auf eine
gesundheitsgefährdung durch cocktail
effekte
die beamten verweisen auf zwei eu
studien diese besagen das pestizid
cocktails wahrscheinlich sind für die
schilddrüse
auch das nervensystem allerdings mit
unterschiedlichem grad an sicherheit
auswirkungen auf andere organe oder aufs
immunsystem aber sind unbekannt kein
grund für eine generelle entwarnung
sagte mir drei toxikologen ich denke
wenn man halt eine mischung hat von 100
verschiedenen stoffen und man letztlich
bei 1 stoffen dass endlich den grenzwert
ausschütten dann kann man sich ganz klar
in größeren orten wo effekte auftreten
also von daher wundert mich diese
aussage durchaus
wofür haben wir den start wir haben den
staat der die pestizide reguliert und
dann könnte man ja einfach sagen ich
kann essen was ich will wir haben ja das
problem ist dass der staat mehrere
schutzziele halt betrachten muss zum
einen das schutzziel der gesundheit der
bevölkerung und zum anderen das
schutzziel der ernährer verfügung also
dass genügend nahrungsmittel zur
verfügung steht der stab ist dem dilemma
und der ist nicht sein thema
[Musik]
wie stark ist die bevölkerung mit
pestiziden und andere chemikalien
belastet die behörden wissen es nicht
eine pilotstudie läuft im eu vergleich
liegen wir um jahre zurück
[Musik]
es gibt zeiten in denen ich die
gartenarbeit nicht machen kann ich spüre
meine finger dann nicht mehr ich habe
keine kraft mehr
felix doch sagt 69 in den 1980 er und 90
er jahren war ein bauer und spritzte
pestizide davor hatte er in einer salz
mine gearbeitet und einmal im jahr mit
giftigen stoffen hantiert
2012 die diagnose parkinson
was denken sie ist der gruß ihrer
krankheit
chemische produkte
schuld sind weiß ich nicht aber diese
mittel haben schon ihre wirkung
zwar gibt es keine direkten beweis dass
man wegen einen bestimmten pestizid
krank wird wenn ich an den cocktail
denke die mich ausgesetzt war und
in frankreich ist parkinson eine
anerkannte berufskrankheit bei bauern
die schweiz aber hat keine
gesundheitsdaten zu bauen das
staatssekretariat für wirtschaft
verweist auf ausländische studien wer
beruflich irgendeinem pestizid
ausgesetzt ist habe an mindestens 50
prozent höheres risiko an parkinson zu
erkranken
schon als jugendlicher hat felix doch
sei seinem vater beim ausbringen von
pestiziden in den 1960 er jahren
[Musik]
ich habe meinem vater geholfen die nicht
den traktor fuhr er saß hinten mit einer
art lanze mit er spritzte
ich war vorne und steuerte den traktor
praktisch ungeschützt hätten sie das
längst verbotene pestizid par akkord
verspritzt paraquat steht im verdacht
das risiko einer parkinson erkrankung zu
erhöhen vielleicht haben sich schon als
kind vergiftet
haben sie mal mit ihrem vater darüber
gesprochen aber
ich habe meinen vater und meine mutter
im gespräch unterbrochen und ihnen
gesagt
ihr seid nicht verantwortlich
ich sagte den schuldigen muss man nicht
bei euch suchen
die opel linie und die behörden auf
jeden fall
mit der freundlichen unterstützung und
dem segen der detailhändler
felix doch sei der einzige bauer der
bereit war vor der kamera über seine
krankheit zu sprechen
in der deutschschweiz habe ich drei
andere an parkinson erkrankte bauen
angefragt keiner wollte darüber reden
jeder zeigt mit dem finger auf den
anderen der bauer auf den handel der
handel auf den konsumenten der konsument
auf die agrochemie die agrochemie auf
die behörden
[Musik]
die bundesbehörden bewilligen die
pestizide es ist an ihnen auflagen zu
verfügen das die gifte keinen schaden
anrichten
jetzt verbietet die schweiz das bild
vernichtungsmittel rotary
club harmonie der stoff dran aber
gewisse konzentration
präsentiert krippen
verunreinigt mit pestizid in der schweiz
muss das trinkwasser für eine million
menschen neu aufbereitet werden
[Musik]
das hat allgemein bio ist aber wenn ich
mit kollege redet natürlich schon
vorgezeichnet
die fungizid rückstand im grundwasser
rehner gespritzt das sieht 40 jahre plus
-
entschuldigung hat das näher überprüft
das hat natürlich den schumpeter falls
es klappt alles genau
kantonschemiker wie kurz einer
kontrollieren das grundwasser auf
abbauprodukte von pestiziden sie sind
dafür verantwortlich dass unser
trinkwasser einwandfrei ist
[Musik]
die firma sie nicht alle angeschlagen
der letzte dutzende vorjahr als das
problem sind abbauprodukte
um mir eine geküsst das digi du meine
güte war für dich dass es geht will die
informationen die nur zulässig stellt
respektiv besteht hersteller vor zehn
jahren hat kurz einer darum den bund
geschrieben gestützt auf das
öffentlichkeitsgesetz
verlangte er auskunft über die
abbauprodukte von heiklen pestiziden und
was ich stand ja
antworte ich sie darum fans jetzt groß
so ist das zur verfügung stelle jedoch
ist zu umfangreich das sind möglich
unter anderem aufgrund von
geschäftsgeheimnis fordert pestizid
herstellen das ist jedes gefühl dass sie
das schreiben vom bundesamt für
landwirtschaft
macht mir halt ruft etwas kontrollieren
in der umwelt also told us geschäfts
kann ist aus meiner sicht
also letztlich ist das zögern auf küste
oder belasten völker gegangen
was sagt die zulassungsstelle zu dieser
kritik
nichts auch auf nachfrage nicht
sie schreibt nur im verhältnis bund und
kantone sei nicht das
öffentlichkeitsgesetz maßgeblich sondern
es gelten besondere regelungen
besondere regelungen staatsrechtler
sagen es geht die bundesverfassung und
der grundsatz bund und kantone
unterstützen einander in der erfüllung
ihrer aufgaben und arbeiten zusammen sie
schulten einander rücksicht und beistand
[Musik]
der kampf
um informationen
naja
das erste pestizid mit dem wirkstoff
chloroquin
zugelassen 1970
zwei jahre bevor pestizide schweizweit
überhaupt reguliert wurden
der bund hatte damals noch keine
toxikologen und zog externe spezialisten
bei
er habe pestizid studien gratis in
seiner freizeit für den bund beurteilt
sagt christian schlatter damals tätig
beim toxikologischen institut der eth
und uni zürich
rohstoff habe rund zehn stunden
gebraucht
erst 1982 stellte der bund einen
toxikologen an um schlotter zu
unterstützen
[Musik]
schlosser sagte damals bei zugelassenen
pestiziden bestehe keine krebsgefahr
pflanzenschutzmittel wo könnte krebs
erzeugen die wäre gar nicht zu bekommen
die werden vorher durch intensive
untersuchungen ein modellsystem und ihr
experiment auf ihre klubs wirksamkeit
abdrehen und vanessa positiv sie doch
integrale durfte werden im fall von
katalonien aber wie es schon damals eine
studie auf die krebsgefahr hin
1978 schrieb das amerikanische
krebsforschungsinstitut
chlor o tel o neal war krebserregend in
ratten versuchen die ratten entwickelten
nierentumoren
schon 40 jahre vor dem verbot schrieb
das institut quartal o'neal sei
ein potenzielles risiko für den menschen
damals aber reichte das nicht aus um ein
pestizid zu verbieten vergleichbar mit
der gefahr durch einen hai der in
grosser distanz zum menschen schwimmt
erst bei einem risiko erst wenn der hai
direkt auf einen menschen zu schwimmt
und der mensch gefressen werden könnte
wurde ein pestizid verboten seit 2011
aber gelten strengere regeln in der eu
und der schweiz jetzt reicht die gefahr
dass ein hai anwesend ist unabhängig von
der distanz um ein pestizid zu verbieten
das heißt es wird verboten wenn es aus
wahrscheinlich krebserregend eingestuft
wird seitdem paradigmawechsel wurde
chronologie erst 2016 überprüft und erst
2019 verboten
herstellerin syngenta hat gegen das
verbot geklagt sie wehrt sich gegen die
einstufung wahrscheinlich krebserregend
gibt es weitere heikle pestizide im
trinkwasser das wird jetzt abgeklärt der
bund publiziert unterdessen einen teil
der pestizid ab baustoffe aufgrund des
drucks der kontrolle
auch die politik macht druck das
pestizid risiko muss bis in fünf jahren
halbiert werden im vergleich zur
situation vor zehn jahren warum ist aber
überhaupt soviel pestizid im bach die
zulassungsstelle müsse das gift doch so
regulieren dass es keinen schaden
anrichtet
die antwort verblüfft die behörden
berücksichtigen zwei wichtige eintrags
wege für pestizide in gewässer bei der
zulassung nicht
in der nähe der felder stehen schweiz
weit über eine million schächte wenn es
nach dem spritzen regnet werden
pestizidrückstände über leitungen und
entwässerungsrohre in bäche geschwemmt
[Musik]
rund ein drittel der pestizid menge im
bauch stammt von diesen zwei eintrags
wegen
man sei daran maßnahmen dagegen
abzuklären heißt es beim bund
das meiste gift im gewässer aber stammt
vom bauernhof einige bauern burschen
ihre spritzen früher auf dem hofplatz
ohne pestizidrückstände aufzufangen das
gift kaum sowie schächte ins gewässer
roland kreis firma hat darum vor drei
jahren einen unterirdischen auffangtank
gebaut
an dir gewiss dass das problem ist die
geschäftsbedingungen ein wenig selbst
wenig beachtung schenkte dreifach kein
techniker ernst eine quiz vor
aber so viel stand für umwelt hat zwei
vollzugs richtlinien wie mir dass er
noch hat er brauchte tourer kostet daher
5000 franken da haben wir
schon machen aber da sind die
vorschriften sind eben dzeko soll doch
ein anderer machen mit dem holzhammer
bis in den märz erlassen schutzhütten
stage auf denen es darf kein fremdes
stoff werner krah sie in das glas
rotieren die regatta nur genau warum
erst vor zwei jahren haben die ersten
kantone begonnen die plätze der bauen zu
kontrollieren
unseren entschuldigung mehr haltbar da
stehen schon und jeder hat selber gut
auf remis
da ist ja
warum aber kommt der druck ist jetzt
seit 30 jahren steht im gesetz das keine
verunreinigungen stoffe in gewässer
gelangen dürfen
die sensibilität dass das repräsentieren
bedeutende nitrat leistet ihr
zweifelsohne taxi aber das bafu hat
schon 20 tritt zusammen mit dem
bundesamt für landwirtschaft
vollzugshilfe sei wo ein punkt den ich
ihr mündliches
platzregen und sanierer
steht ist einfach im nachhinein kann man
sich aufregen die hand das
wasserschutzgebiet nur zwei
konnten georg burkhardt bis jetzt dann
ist das ja nicht so gebaut dass krieg
so viel bestätigen sie haben beschränkt
wissen was man hat sich die sich höhne
mehr aufmerksamkeit eine punktuelle
scheint
man das komische sache
[Musik]
das ist die liste der pestizide die 1989
bewilligt waren oder sich für die mikro
produziert habe
zwei drittel dieser pestizide sind heute
verboten zu gefährlich für die umwelt
und die menschen
[Musik]
auch das nervengift chlorpyrifos
es dauerte aber mehr als ein halbes
jahrhundert bis die behörden das gift
verboten haben
[Musik]
das erste pestizid mit globuli fonds
wurde
1976 provisorisch zugelassen
aufgrund von welchen studien die
zulassungsstelle war es nicht
erst 20 jahre später erst in den 1990 er
jahren wurde an jungen ratten untersucht
wie das gift auf die gehirnentwicklung
von embryos wirkt
die amerikanische hersteller firma dow
agrosciences
fasste die resultate der studie zusammen
chlorpyrifos schädigt die
gehirnentwicklung von ratten nicht das
heißt keine gefahr für den menschen
zehn jahre später aber ist alles anders
wissenschaftler warnen in mehreren
studien vor gehirn anomalien bei kindern
die eu bezweifelt die aussagekraft
dieser studien zunächst und so dauert es
weitere acht jahre bis sie das
nervengift
2020 verbietet
auch wegen der erkenntnisse eines
deutschen chemikers der in schweden lebt
auf dem weg zu ihm frage ich mich
brauchte es wirklich ein halbes
jahrhundert um herauszufinden dass
chlorpyrifos kinder schädigen kann nein
sagt axel er schaffte es an die geheime
studie von claude puel fonds
heranzukommen was haben sie denn
rausgefunden
der pc hersteller hat eine falsche
zusammenfassung der zulassungsstudie an
die behörden eingereicht ich habe anhand
der rohdaten haus gefunden dass die
entwicklung der gehirne der affen jungen
beschädigt ist und zwar schon bei der
kleinsten getesteten dosis klubboss das
geht aber nicht aus dem testbericht
hervor und auch nicht aus der
zusammenfassung des herstellers das
heißt schon die kleinste menge
chlorpyrifos kann kinder schädigen
erinnern sie sich noch was ihr erster
gedanke aus herausgefunden haben ich
hätte mich dran ich saß in meinem büro
und war schon ziemlich geschockt
das heißt für die fonds hätte damals
1998 gar nicht zugelassen werden ganz
genau entweder hätte es 1998 verboten
werden müssen oder oder der für
gebrauchte stark eingeschränkten müssen
und warum hatten dass die
zulassungsbehörde nicht gemerkt ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass sie sich
nicht die zeit genommen haben diese 800
seiten oder 900 seiten ganz durchzulesen
sie hätten bis auf seite 6 164 lesen
müssen und dann die entsprechenden
statistischen analysen machen müssen
dann hätten sie den effekte von denen
ich auch identifiziert haben ein insider
der schweizer behörden bestätigt wenn
die zeit dränge lese man nur die
zusammenfassungen der hersteller statt
der detaillierten studien
die preisfrage ist jetzt natürlich ist
auch ein trauriger einzelfall oder nur
die spitze des eisbergs
ich denke es ist kein einzelfall
der hersteller hat immer ein interesse
daran dass das die eigenen produkte als
sicher da stehen damit sie so viel wie
möglich davon verkaufen kann das heißt
eben das zulassungssystem das kann so
heute nicht sicher verhindern dass wir
geschädigt werden korrekt und das ist
doch schockieren
was sagt die zulassungsstelle zu diesem
vorwurf
nichts konkretes auf
bitter und präzisierung nochmals
derselbe wortlaut
pflanzenschutzmittel werden nur
zugelassen wenn sie die kriterien der
pflanzenschutzmittel verordnung erfüllen
intern aber wird die verordnung
kritisiert der gesundheitsschutz sei in
gefahr heißt es in der neuen
zulassungsstelle dies weil die
verordnung verändert wurde auf antrag
der alten zulassungsstelle dem bundesamt
für landwirtschaft
[Musik]
früher waren pestizide nämlich nur
befristet bewilligt gleich wie in der eu
artikel 19 aber wurde 2009 10 gestrichen
seither sind pestizide für immer
zugelassen
zwar können teilbereiche überprüft
werden aber dafür bekommen die
toxikologen keine vollständigen daten
pakete mehr
in internen protokollen klagen sie die
datenlage sei anders als in der eu
zunehmend veraltet und bruchstückhaft
die aufgaben des gesundheitsschutzes
können nur mit vollständigen und
transparenten unterlagen erfolgen
überprüft der pestizide werden oft
strenger reguliert im vergleich zur
datenfülle der eu aber
fühlen sich die toxikologen im blindflug
sie wollen die verordnung wieder
verschärfen
das nervengift chlorpyrifos dass kinder
schädigen kann aber ist verboten könnte
man meinen
trotz des verbots kommt das gift aber
weiterhin in die schweiz
delius tyler
in jeder dritten lebensmittelprobe aus
asien ist zuviel pestizid
zb potpourri fonds oder andere pestizide
die in der schweiz verboten sind
im zürcher kantonsrat leitet andrea
schürmann die pestizid analyse
er hat das nervengift chlorpyrifos
2020 in jeder siebten grube gefunden in
21 proben war die menge so hoch dass das
lebensmittel gesundheitsschädigend war
oder vielleicht ja
das ist riesig und sie zu groß
die neue toxischen effekte zum geboren
das
größte problem
mit stickstoff werden die proben
gefroren händler mit gesundheit
schädigen der ware werden nicht gesperrt
andrea schürmann fehlt die gesetzliche
grundlage fehlbare händler könne er nur
zwingen ihre ware vor dem verkauf zu
testen und erreicht strafanzeige ein die
busen aber seien gering rund 2000
franken
[Musik]
es ist natürlich weil man mit herzblut
dahinter ist und gesagt dass das sachen
verlauf dann durchaus noch die
hand im preis für die probleme und rein
händen und die firma eni übernehmen
und wenn du bist echt leid tut schweiz
aus allagen und dann später über
natürlich immer wieder turrini bei peri
falls dauerte es ein jahr bis die
schweiz die strengeren eu werte übernahm
so lange waren auch als
gesundheitsschädigend geltende
lebensmittel im umlauf die toxikologisch
begründet dass auch muss man viel
strenger sie viel schneller sie und
übergangsfristen gar nicht oder sehr
minimal halten damit männer
konsumentenschützerin
der fokus auf pestizide allein aber sei
künstlich sagen toxikologen eigentlich
müssten die behörden den ganzen
chemikalien mix regulieren den wir
ausgesetzt sind plastik schwermetalle
flammschutzmittel kosmetika etc aber da
steht auch die eu noch ganz am anfang
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es wurde
unglaublich
große
[Musik]
mitarbeiter an die
haben sie angst dass es künftig mehr
parken von fälle geben wird
ich habe keine angst ich bin wütend es
ist gut dass es leute gibt die andere
leute wie mich in diese situation
bringen
und jetzt kann man nicht mehr sagen dass
man es nicht wusste früher wusste man
vielleicht nicht um die gefahren aber
jetzt kennt man sie
dabei an ihm sicher stellt sie mit der
initiative ist
immer eine wende bloss sechs
patientinnen
[Musik]
krise
das freut mich wirklich ob er als
zeichen schweizer landwirtschaft 40 von
der lieth wind eine nachhaltige
landwirtschaft sodass so als würden so
wie vor 20 jahren die jede branche
herrscht und staub blieben und
landwirtschaft blieb gar nicht ob er
noch einfach nicht von null auf hundert
prozent
das gold nicht
mit dem druck der politik kommen
bestechend einfache lösungen auf
abdecken von schächten damit pestizide
beim spritzen nicht in gewässer gelangen
und sieht man mache da solche stiftung
und als alternative zu pestiziden
biologische duftstoffe gegen schädlinge
die sogenannte 4x methode damit man die
pläne sind
hochbegabte stattfinden also sind wir
total verwirrt
im zürcher weinland erntet michael
frauenfelder seinen raps zum letzten mal
pflanze keinen neuen mehr an das
pyrethroide dass er gespritzt aufbaut
nicht mehr eingesetzt werden und je
weniger mittel desto eher werden
schädlinge resistent
das erntejahr 20 21 sehr schlecht wegen
dem vielen regen auch darum sein
pestizide nach wie vor nötig sagt er
als pur wird es schwieriger spagat
zwischen ökologisch nachhaltige
wirtschaftlichkeit
und der konsumenten
das sind soviel spagat und das spielfeld
wo wir momentan stünden und ja ab und zu
aber nicht aus
[Musik]
ab diesem jahr fordert der handel müssen
nachhaltiger produziert werden bauern
sollen resistente sorten anbauen dass
apple die gegen krankheiten resistent
sind und weniger gespritzt werden müssen
das ist hier sollte dobers wo die
bekannte stattliche der von der
art und die muss man nichts weniger
sprit spritzte weniger ein drittel
weniger also das bringt was bringt sich
orbis und erschaffe die auch für lidl
nimmt jetzt lidl der doper sei die hand
zum teil nach der sich entweder unter
umständen fertig werden wenn die partei
im ladenregal league geblieben aber wir
führen gezielt aus österreich für mir
schleierhaft wie einsiedler schreibt man
auch nachhaltigkeit öko
und durch die andere tätigkeit besonders
zum sortiment
er macht weniger umsatz erzeugt
besonders da ich da der sind der knall
hört doch unter der profit von
ökologischem denken
[Musik]
resistente sorten fordern aber nicht
verkaufen
[Musik]
liegen schreibt aus
wettbewerbstechnischen gründen wolle man
nicht sagen ob das sortiment angepasst
werde
und die umstrittene gen technik
nicht nur sie würde es schaffen den
beliebten gala ganz ohne pestizide zu
züchten
[Musik]
keine perfekte lösung in sicht
und wir alle sind teil des pestizid
pokers
[Musik]
agrochemie behörden bauern campbell und
konsument
es ist an uns zu bestimmen was uns
wichtiger ist mehr ernte sicherheit oder
mehr schutz für die umwelt tiere und
menschen
[Musik]